tá boa tarde a todos
e hoje tenho que falar de economia a
economia não é o primeiro tema mais
interessante dependendo e contar a
versão exclusive cativar para aprender
um pouco mais sobre economia e uma
caminhão seria diferente
ora nós aprendemos na escola e penso que
esta altura já se cruza forma de texto
informação é nós aprendemos na escola
que a economia certa forma funciona é
sente é duas áreas das famílias
desempregados
as empresas não pagam salários nas
pessoas
as pessoas que conheci olhos compram os
pães e os produtos é que as empresas
produzem e equívoca volta diz que custa
conjeturando que criamos inventamos o
resto é o resto é extra 15 em completo
ou seja uma economia que aparece um
fluxo regular mas falta que muita coisa
nessa história volta o fato muito famosa
analisamos também o desempenho das
empresas de forma incompleta ou seja
novas chamas com sucesso de empresas
o medo faz as vendas que tá aí faça
lucro a autor num investimento as
proteções e isso é apenas é isso nós
aprendemos a pensar as empresas ea
economia mais vender melhor quanto mais
tiver a melhor ea organizações que
processam a informação me alimentos
entre estas um homem muito sucesso
informação das empresas para vender essa
informação é fundo de investimento
depois entre r$2 20 das empresas uma
empresa ela a mais bem vindo seja qual é
o nível de desempenho da empresa
entrante cimento o sucesso de uma
empresa em termos internacionais com
base naquelas naquela informação é fina
sério e contido em nós mesmos que o
mundo acabe é que o mercado consegue
encontrar um ponto de equilíbrio nunca
vi tudo que você já tenha visto retomar
a oferta da própria oferta é isso indo
que nós vamos assumir entre os recursos
naturais
não devemos preocupar primeiro com os
recursos atuais porque a partir do meu
corpo escultural fi é que comece a
consumir uma quantidade maior eu preciso
vai ficar mais caro e portanto a empresa
vai vender mais caro e eu vou comprar
menos e dessa forma é a quantidade de
gás natural volta ao seu estado como
acontece que estão assim por um simples
motivo é que quando a economia de
mercado que nós temos hoje em dia e que
não tem nada a ver vai vai com aquilo
que ela somente disso é uma parte não
vou falar isso adoro mexer conhecimento
que quiser pensar a não se meter comigo
no meu caso não é nada daquilo que nós
temos hoje a economia mudar nós temos
hoje na realidade é não se preocupar com
o futuro evitando embora os impactos das
missões 900 kg comigo mercado hoje não
se pergunta se não sei porque dez anos o
tempo as primeiras rodadas não é um tema
de hoje é um tema só daqueles antigo
amigo mercado atualmente vivo no espaço
23 anos que é esse o seu tema prende
opção senão preocupando com o pai
dizendo isto então meu amigo mercado
nunca vai encontrar um político nato que
vai calcular a sociedade com conteúdo em
si
aos 15 anos ele estudou economia linear
que foi bom foi com um respondeu quando
é realizada a ii em 1981 há muito tempo
44% da população mundial vivia a empresa
extrema tanto faz muita atenção por via
não existia ainda que em 2015 esses são
apenas 10% da população mundial que vive
nesta quinta por pobreza extrema onde
funcionou precisa agora mudar tudo mas
conseguiu destaque do trabalho fazer com
que sua experiência e aprendi na vida
mas por outro lado isso também deixou
claro que agora precisamos de minimizar
este lado de dentro
o lado negativo é viver com que com o
dia de nome de todos os eventos que deu
origem à melhoria da qualidade de vida
de rico
na realidade nós o pib aumenta quando
nós conseguimos mas queria isso com
1.800 empresas para virem alguém tem que
consumir os materiais das empresas
isso significa que com sol céu vários
níveis de dólares formas em várias
partes do mundo mas o fato é que alguns
de nós vamos pensar um pouco e não vou
que aumentaram em vender não vamos
conseguir não explodiu é quinta começa
hoje
nesta hora é de pensar qual é a origem o
discurso nas mãos o que quer que
aconteça que pesquisar a história do
qual foi meu nome foi utilizado os
recursos foram conseguidos por pegada
ecológica e ambiental no contexto social
é certo e é isso que estamos aqui a
falar
brancos ou de aumentar porque a
população mundial ainda vai aumentar
muito o nosso tempo de deus o doutor
richard 8 mil milhões mas em 2050 não
tinha porque em termos de 30 segundos ao
mundial vai aumentar com esta com este
grau
eu não queira consumir um vai querer o
movimento tem todo o direito em
conseguir 50 mil classe médica
melhoramento contínuo rendimentos
aumentado nos últimos anos
toda a gente está no seu pleno direito
de crer que já conseguiu ter sua casa e
portanto isso implica no momento do
consumo de gás
isso é o ponto em que gostamos os ao
nível dos materiais após conversar com
esta imagem tentar transmitir exatamente
só seja nós hoje em r 3 minutos com o
mundo com sua monumental igual ao do
total enquanto estiver aqui falar sobre
- são vários sites todos dessa natureza
foram conseguidos mundo
é importante ter uma imagem de deus pra
pensar que candidatura inglesa que não
consome duas quinzenas a outra ou outras
perguntas nem pensar foi o assunto nem
comigo 40 títulos são culpa do zero ea
pensar em caixão de materiais que são
sábios telemóveis os resultados temos a
grande taxa zero
o caixão de minerais que fazem com que
seja possível a seus materiais
existentes consciência que há estudos
que indicam que esse material já tem uma
data limite ou seja a materiais que
estiva e ele não hesitou
a disputa deve procurar os alunos já em
2009 de 4 99% é que a mensagem pensar e
nós estamos aí fui considerado mais
digitalizado faz todo sentido é preciso
é pensar já como é que vamos utilizar
mais tempo possível esses materiais são
dos casos para permitir que nós vivemos
tempos em que fizemos 50 para manter o
nosso estilo de vida temos um saldo de
três planetas
isso não vai acontecer nada fizeram em
2050 certeza conteúdos mesmo estudo e de
termos os porque se isso for necessário
passar notas planetas
depois a complexo na altura o ser humano
que entra em conflito com o custo da
copa
é uma questão de sobrevivência eo
movimento que não reduzam hoje cerca de
nosso estranho muito estranho
cerca de 105 milhões de toneladas de
materiais que puder
só que em 2050 esse estudo aplica lago
de capital aumento da produção e não vai
gostar do consumidor e demais materiais
é mais tecnológicas onde é preciso
dedicar este materiais e pedro losi
autos a mais 160 os materiais do que com
nossos alunos em 2005
então nós tinham vida vai implicar no
aumento do consumo entre as dez anos
atrás não tínhamos aquela nove óbitos ou
em três anos entre os 44 e os dois
computadores que assim o 31 lutando muay
thai há certa tradição dos fios via
tecnologia que precisam muito legais
para isso
a questão é o estresse um cenário
negativo previsto escolas coisas
negativas têm circulado positivo é como
é que eu vou pensar que é exatamente a
mesma coisa comece cobre ultrapassar
tudo isto é ver que este problema é a
sua finalidade é só uma ótima forma
episódio família que essa nova forma de
pensar a economia é que começa a chamada
economia se move o que é este comício 4
nós prendemos um caminho linear não é o
que você come alencar
todos torcem isso consumo ao mesmo e daí
tudo que sobra pro echo o amor à
camisola fica velha que fala citou
outras muita quantidade vai para os
aterros após o casamento que nós a este
implica é que há imensos materiais podem
ser reutilizados produtos que não só
eventualmente nos lucros que está este
ano saltou antes da bicicleta em tom de
voz em off durante campanhas de
reciclagem plano nos últimos anos
nettles reciclar os materiais para votar
apesar disso também na área mas ela
surge o conceito economias humano e
come-se quarta em de licenciamento com
que com o inter ea utilização do produto
nós nos ajudamos mais que um grande
negócio em cima do lado usar um produto
ou seja imaginamos temos um tiro na nuca
2010 em todo o lado é reutilizar os
materiais recuperados materiais em vez
do um micro ondas
eu posso ir parao e ter esse time ter
esses incentivos para os colorados
dessa forma eu toparia materiais que
tenham consciência de fazer
assim ele está como nós vamos incluir 14
a falar de usar o produto durante o
maior trio do tempo esse choque muito
conteúdo não estamos habituados é
conseguir pensar e é tempo ensinar
pequenos resíduos elas sejam desviadas
dos produtos materiais 15 anos mantendo
11 anos encontrado antes mesma roupa
pensar como é que eu vou fazer aqui
informa que no final da nfc 10 isso
realmente a pensar como é não reutilizar
as coisas pararam as coisas que não
faturar bicicleta tudo certo e pensar em
bolinha eles terem comido do cruzeiro é
de fora é e cruzar fiuza e voltar a usar
porque isso quando está pensado também é
te faz mais sentido já não é fácil
porque levava estudos que ninguém
consuma economia exatas do forma o pib
pode chegar a 700 estudos que indicam
que até 2030 não vem cá meu pai é nossa
obrigação dos princípios da economia
circular alto do céu que menos deu certo
e uma criança também de 170 mil postos
de trabalho ou seja a economia circular
não é que está a falar do meu amigo fiel
estarei lá vindo um monte de economia
capaz de construir nosso twitter a
criação de emprego no fundo é tudo que o
conflito é concreto ele explica que a
juntar um carro a arrancar um ponto há
uma máquina de lavar roupa muito
visitaria 15 milhões em 2010 um site que
os mafiosos mais perigosos
porque tem um caso tentando que nós
apenas um dos 15 que vai com 31
o assunto causa é um pré requisito do
nosso jeito é não acontece porque
voltamos o flamengo consegue fornecer
suporte tanto agora conheci qualifying e
vamos repensar o que nós precisamos
incluir tentamos é falar de uma forma de
frente que é essa busca de um espaço eu
ensinar não é ter possuído por carro
é a minha cidade é que o carro não deu
serviço que eu preciso é o substituto
provável confronto
eu posso não ser dona do carro mas
outros assim mesmo que significam me
juntar a computadores daquela nova
reserva começou porque a máquina de
lavar são de uma máquina pública na
pequena casa de silvia no edifício de 15
mil desde que a gigante acontecido mas
não aguentou a pressão e desenvolvimento
de projetos para captação e tudo isto dá
origem a novos produtos e novos negócios
podem surgir há vários exemplos de
negócios já dão sul nunca tínhamos uma
receita é focados nestes concelhos
pareçam a um site que vocês podem que
vem quem sabe por isso sai e vêm com o
senhor ter muito mais informação no site
do ministério público mp só eu tanto
exemplos concretos não fala que o
negócio já com esta filosofia é para
terminar isso conceito é você show
futuro aquilo que eu proponho é e sejam
em número os creminhos que pensa em
forma não curada
aquilo que aconteceu no passado
não vai acontecer no futuro é um dos
grandes filmes começa eo v e abusa de
criança teve nada de emoção e bem pior
se a estes temas da sua campeonato você
encontra se junto com amigos nessa chapa
única forma que isto vai funcionar
é que seja um livro bonito estranhos
sentimentos tempo fazer estes fãs
só assim é que se consegue juntar é que
o que é o correto nós achamos que o feto
hoje cidade utilizando o mesmo tempo em
que o feto na final enquanto testemunhas
entre funcionários e três tentativas dos
aviões utilizados hoje nosso cérebro nas
mesmas escolas aprendemos na escola de
dança aumento dos anos mais o aveo além
das contas o lado mais técnico e eu
precisava de preços século 21 é preciso
momento desenvolver lado da emoção
lá vem porque só assim vamos conseguir
encontrar a solução dos problemas que
são todos os filiados como a composição
de obra de cervantes
muito bom